pond preparation brief intro
various steps for preparing pond are
described below
controlling harmful aquatic plants and
animals
aquatic weeds consumes almost all the
nutrition from water
eradicating cannibalistic and unwanted
fish
applying lawn applying fertilizer
before a pond can be restocked for a new
crop the excessive wastes
which accumulate in the pond during the
previous crop must be removed in the
soil and water conditioned
growing of coefficient an improperly
prepared pond may lead to difficulty in
pond management during the culture
period
which could result in a decrease in
production capacity of the pond
the cleaning of a pond or removal of the
wastes especially the organic and
phosphatic wastes that have accumulated
in the pond bottom could be
accomplished by drying lambing and
plowing
however these methods could still leave
an adverse effect on the water and soil
quality in the pond
which could result in a decrease in the
production capacity of the pond
there are two methods for cleaning a
pond according to the possibility of the
pond
to be dried
dry method this method is used when the
pond bottom can be dried completely
the pond is drained and left to dry in
the sun for a period of 10 to 30 days
then the waste is removed either
manually or mechanically and transported
to the waste dumping area
removal of waste by machines has an
advantage that it can compact the bottom
soil
however this cleaning method by drying
may lead to development of acidity
lowering the level of the pond bottom
and the diffusion of waste if the
workers are inexperienced
one method in areas where the pond
cannot be dried completely
pressure washing can be used to flush
out the wastes
this method takes a shorter time and is
more efficient than the dry method
flushing should be continued until the
acid and dark anaerobic layer in the
soil are removed
this method is suitable in the acid
sulfate areas where the oxidation of the
soil must be avoided
however the method requires a
sedimentation pond to all settlement of
the suspended wastes to avoid
contaminating the drainage canal in the
natural environment
the remaining pathogens in the ponds can
be eliminated during the limiting
process
limit once the pond is cleaned it is
then filled with water and left
overnight before flushing out to remove
debris and elevate the ph
this process should be repeated until
the ph of the water remains above seven
and only then the lime is applied the
types of wine to be used depend on the
water ph
it is recommended that agricultural lime
calcium carbonate
calco 3 dot or dolomite magnesium
carbonate
ideally camg co3 2 should be used in a
pond with water ph near neutral and the
hydrated line calcium hydroxide
is an inorganic compound with the
chemical formula ca
oh two should be used in a pond with
water ph below five
the amount of line to be used should be
carefully calculated to avoid inducing
an excessively high water ph
which may increase ammonia toxicity and
result in the mortality of the koi fish
liming continued the lime requirement of
the pond depends on the soil ph
the measurement of the soil ph should be
determined either by the wet soil method
or by the dry soil method
during the application lime should be
spread throughout the pond bottom and up
to the top of the dike
a large portion of lime should be
applied over the feeding areas and to
all parts of the pond that have remained
wet
when the pond is properly lined and
filled with water the average water ph
should be between 7.5 to 8.5 with daily
fluctuation of less than 0.5
agricultural lime dolomite or hydrated
lime at 100 kg
day should be added to maintain the
required ph
eradication of predators after liming
the pond should be filled to the maximum
depth through a screen with fine mesh to
prevent the predators and competitors
from entering the pond
these animals including fish link snake
head zone hello and in local dialect
crustaceans and some invertebrates may
compete for food
prey on the koi fry or carry diseases
and parasites
they may establish themselves in the
pond that is not effectively screened
effectively or is left for a long period
of time
eradication of predators continued some
chemicals should be used to eradicate
these animals in the pond before
stalking
snails can be eliminated by the
application of quickline chow
at 5 30 kg slash hot and sun dried for
two to three days
bleaching powder bleaching powder or
calcium hypochlorite
caocl2 is another practical and safe
fish toxicant
it kills all the predatory and wheat
fish of the pond when applied at the
rate of 25 to 30 ppm
tripod etal 1980.
however during storage significant
chlorine content is lost and hence it is
always safer to use the commercially
available bleaching powder at the rate
of 35 to 50 ppm or 350 to 500 kg
m of water fish kill occurs within one
to three hours and the toxicity lasts
for three to five days
eradication of predators continued
plankton invented fauna start developing
from the seventh or eighth day after
treatment
chlorine content of the bleaching powder
thoroughly disinfects the pond which is
essential in undrainable ponds where
disinfection by sun drying is not at all
possible
disinfection of the pond is one of the
essential measures for maintaining
proper health condition of the fish
besides it also satisfies the lime
requirement of the pond soil
the method of application is also
relatively simple
the powder is mixed with water and
uniformly spread over the entire water
surface
distressed and dead fish are removed by
netting chlorine killed fish are safe
for human consumption
eradication of predators continued
calculation of dose
the required quantity of poison can be
calculated using the following formulae
for rectangular ponds see formula below
equals required amount of poison in kg
eradication of predators continued
calculation of dose
for circular pawns see formula below
equals required amount of poison in kg
fertilization the pond must be
fertilized with either organic or
inorganic fertilizer to stimulate the
plankton bloom in order to provide shade
to the pond bottom and utilize the
nitrogenous and phosphate wastes within
the pond
the shade will also prevent the growth
of harmful benthic algae
the sun-dried chicken manure is the most
common organic fertilizer
to be used in the amount of 200-300 kg
slash hot
the miner must be soaked in water for 24
hours before it is spread over the
surface of the water
fertilization continued inorganic
fertilizers
such as urea 46 n and compound
fertilizers like
ammonium phosphate 16 colon 20 colon
zero
or those with npk combination of 16
hours 16 minutes and 16 seconds
can be used at 20 30 kg slash hot
the fertilizer must be dissolved in
water before it is spread over the water
surface to avoid precipitation of the
fertilizer onto the pond bottom which
will enrich the soil and accelerate the
growth of benthic algae
fertilization continued after
fertilization
the plankton should bloom within a few
days and the color of the water becomes
slightly green
the fertilizer either the organic or
inorganic should be applied daily in the
pond at five to ten percent of the
initial amount to maintain the plankton
bloom
if the plankton has not bloomed within a
few days additional fertilizer must not
be applied
but plankton-rich water or green water
from the
reservoir should be added